hi I'm Zoe Saldana I'm Zach Galifianakis
we're gonna do the wired autocomplete
interviews I never ask
I do I do
why are my children hate me what is
Galifianakis is real name yeah this is a
stage name Zach Galifianakis I made it
up
so I could get far in the business my
real name is Zach Galifianakis my middle
name is Knight
what is Zach Galifianakis between two
ferns it's an Internet show let me do
your own research well they are doing
what was Zach obvious personally I was a
movie called flushed and it took place
all in the bathroom no yeah the irony
what song I don't know oh I know that
yeah that's all it's hot chilly rain by
the way you're a boy band I think what
sunglasses does Zach Galifianakis we're
in a hangover blue blockers they're real
cheap and they're really really great
glasses blue blockers I got him for my
1-800 number
how Zoe Saldana transforms into Gamora
um it's a it's an arduous process it
starts at 3:30 in the morning where I
hate I hate the world and then I work
for a director that likes to shoot for
16 hours straight so there you go how
did Zoe's hell then I become famous I
don't know how it all is always held
Anna in feet I'm five seven five
how did Joey sell Danis meet Matt go
beta go it's funny you should ask
I kept meeting him at all these parties
and I always kept running in the
opposite direction cuz he just looked
like the biggest player in the room
turns out he was the nicest man I've
ever met
so I got pregnant and I told him you
can't leave and we're having twins and
you're gonna have to marry me I need it
he did how old is always Saldana
I mean we're missing so many articles
here I'm gonna answer for
you did the search and I'm gonna guess
that was probably like 10 years ago so
I'm 26
it's that Galifianakis please don't
that's when because Paul Rudd and I look
so much alike I have a twin brother that
sometimes is in things with me that's
why that's questions there it's that guy
with a neck discreet I'm half Greek and
half Scotch Irish it's a golf and a kiss
a Kappa so I've been asked this before
it's a black fraternity I don't know why
people I mean I'm not gonna answer it
because I just like the mystery of it is
that Galifianakis in boobs Bob's Burgers
I play a couple of people I don't
remember it'll come to me in a minute he
has a weird name is that Galifianakis in
into the wild I played a guy named Kevin
his name was Kevin and it was a small
little role and I play a guy at a bar
basically that was friends with Chris
McCandless the protagonist in the book
and movie is Oh II sell Danna in
Avengers end game I don't know I got a
check for it so well what wait is that a
movie that's already come out I know
it's gonna come out soon and you don't
know if you're in it no oh I was asked
to I was asked to say I don't know is
Zoe Saldana Haitian I'm 3/4 Dominican
and 1/4 Puerto Rican and I do believe
that Dominicans and Haitians like to
love each other sometimes is always held
anti-british I don't know but there's a
woman her name is Tandy Newton and I
believe that we've been confused for
each other is always know then I'm
married to Chris Pratt we were they
didn't work out we tried but we really
did yeah after Anna Faris with Monaco to
Monica was a part of the whole situation
it just didn't work out it didn't work
out I thought he was more of like a
Swardson ager type is zoe saldana
in black panther no I wish I I wish
because they made history is probably
like the only film that has changed
history that I was not in and I'm really
upset about that
who is that girl tonight
I'm a guy who loves life loves his
children loves his wife like a lot of
people okay
who would zach galifianakis dating even
if you asked me when when I was in my
teens 20s 30s the number would be zero
right here
no one zero dates I am married but I'm
dating dating sorry kids
did Zach often ask is seeing Ave Maria
oh yes yes
no in a movie I did but not really I
mean not really did somebody else just
voice I think did Zach Galifianakis gotu
kola college um I did I went to North
Carolina State where I was a film minor
at an agriculture school did Zach
Galifianakis win an Emmy I don't know if
I have I think the show on it and they
gave it to me which is not fair you
still have the Emmy did I get got
misplaced
what does Zoe Saldana look like et I
look like et what movies has Zoe Saldana
been in a lot of like student films a
lot of students there's there's one of
my favorite students name is James
Cameron and he did this small little
movie fresh out of college called avatar
what does Zoe Saldana tattoo say which
one above this one doesn't say anything
it's just a start what ours always held
Anna's twins names sigh ID do because
we're super you know we love art and and
and we just were very ethnic and Bowie
it's here
what does Zoe Saldana eat I eat I eat a
lot I drink more actually than I eat but
you also eat alcohol III alcohol well
that's that's it for the wired Idol what
is it Otto though Idol complete no the
wired autocompletes
segment what we did here is we've just
completed the autocomplete interview
that was my magazine yes